yo guys prestigio what's up and finally
finally finally it's heroin experience
back i'm sorry i was going for a while
in terms of the heroin experience i know
i've been posting semi frequently
but it has it hasn't been enough
definitely not what it should be
so i apologize for that and hopefully
we'll be doing work all right
now for this return episode i thought i
would do something special
and so i'm going to shut up another
yeah i'm going to uh i'm going to bring
in heroin
yep yep finally now to any of you that
are new to the series this is a series
where i just basically do normal
survival
except with like heroin uh and yeah
so usually it's a hair but mod of some
sort
a teleporter mod mod where he shows up
and does random stuff or this mod which
is the most famous
which is he's a violin with a trucker
and he's probably going to kill me
multiple times
and he's going to end the series but i
know you guys want him so let's see this
so for this i'm pretty sure you need two
blocks of gold
you need a piece of another rack and you
need the herb and totem so
so we're going to do on the fishing on
the fishing place so
block of gold block or gold
urban totem and netherrack now last time
when i tried to do this mod it crashed
my game whenever
i summoned inheritance so hopefully that
is not the case of this time
and yeah so i'm just going to light this
up and
nope that was a fail light and bam
because i didn't look like it crashed my
game
um i'm kind of really creeped out
because yeah it's scary bro
i'm scared let's at least have it not
nighttime
oh yeah i did some game mode changing
do some stuff
see the heroin totem will stay lit i
think even if i unlight it
he'll still still be in the game but
yeah so we kind of have to
pursue on even though we got heroin in
the game we got to still
do a normal survival stuff so in
that i'm going to feed
my chicks and cows
so that they get all loaded up
yeah so if everyone shows up i'm just
gonna basically have to
attack him his face
i think that's all that you know
no
so i think all right so
just what's so what's up guys i know
it's been a while since i've done just
some straight up commentary and talk to
you guys
and basically this is like my only
series where i do that sort of type of
commentary
and yeah so um i wanted to talk to you
guys a little bit about
how
i am planning on doing
you saw the sam jackson video which
actually i still have the skin
for force i'm not really a heroin hunter
um if you guys saw the same jacksonville
and you watched it till the very end at
the very end i said i was going to do
this series
about minecraft's largest since there's
a guy who did the series
and it was pretty a pretty popular thing
and
except he did like six different things
which like that's awesome and stuff but
it's
he'd only like did mine diamond ore
uh diamond wheat farm
skeleton maybe melon i think
and like melon slice and just like there
was a lot of stuff that he didn't do
i don't know what i'm doing i'm just
going to go just be like kill a baby
and there's a lot of stuff he didn't do
which
i thought hey you know what if people
are enjoying that
then why don't i finish the series and
obviously finish the series one entail
i'll
like 30 hundred items because there are
a ton of items around well no
not too many there are a lot of
items in minecraft so that would be a
lot of work to do so i'm
i'm gonna do i'm gonna just try doing a
lot i'm just gonna try
just doing a lot more in the series
because people seem to enjoy it
and yeah that's the good stuff but uh so
i'm i'll be working on that i think
those videos will take me a while so i
won't be able to put it out nearly as
fast as the hairband experience
because uh those videos take much
longer because uh it's a lot more
preparation
and since it's all preparation since the
video is just some camera studios
looking some cameras looking at the
finished material i mean like
telling you how many relax it is
so that's gonna be that so hopefully
look forward to that series
i tried doing it with a bookshelf except
the bookshelf turned out half as large
as it should be
um it should go to 256 which is the
maximum building height and there's only
128
and i don't have the base model so i
can't redo it so i'm i'm gonna have to
find out what i
can do with that but yeah and then
i don't know so we'll be doing some some
that'll be some cool stuff
i'm trying to think of what i should do
for the first
uh box first like build thing
and i really haven't decided maybe i'll
do let me get some jungle wood
maybe a sword i was thinking
uh i just cannot jump on that oh
there we go maybe a sword um
oh my gosh i can't even do this i'll
just go right here i'll just climb up
this part
um
there there we can get it we can get oh
we can't destroy that okay
okay all right now let's
start axing our way up
and yeah so i i'm not sure what i want
to do for the first i'm just going to
get this trick
i'm not sure what i want to do for the
first episode i think
i'll go with i'll see our options our
options are
sword and then get i don't have one
more option which should the option be
the option let it be
pork chop pork chop it is
or steak should you take a pork chop
let's do steaks so sword
and good steak
support and get sticks right now
yeah all right first episode
now i'd say it's a little bit easier to
do it with uh
with blocks but
i think it's
how much did i get a stack and a half
second half not bad not bad ugh
all right guys i'm gonna have to head
out to school i just want to do this
video
like you guys what's up so the problem
will be an intro or outro since that
requires me putting it into a movie
editor or putting those things in and
then
having it all process out which takes a
good deal of time
so probably just straight up this
goodness which i'm sure you guys
aren't too worried about most of the
people that watch my stuff my urban
experience
are already subscribers so yeah all
right guys if you enjoyed this
and got to the end make sure you leave a
like right comment and if you're new
subscribe since that's always
appreciated and i would love to have you
on board
on this team there's herbert teams
prestige team
and yeah all right guys i'm prestige
peace out